what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on with fear itself
at this point we pick up with well
basically with the arrival of four with
four showing back up now here's a funny
thing
Thor showing up here after being kind of
banished but not really from Asgard once
he shows up here he immediately arrives
in Broxton Oklahoma now again for those
of you guys who are not really familiar
with for comics Broxton is basically
where he rebuilt Asgard the problem with
this was that the war of Dark Reign
essentially came on the doorsteps of
Roxton to Asgard proper and left the
city in complete and total disarray and
so no one here is too happy to see Thor
yeah everybody's not too happy to see
him they're kind of like man get out of
here like we really don't want to see
you or your problems go away it's kind
of my ex-girlfriend you know just get
out of here I'd rather not see you like
for the rest of my life and so because
of this Thor ends up just sort of making
his way back to the weather you know to
where the rest of the superheroes reside
but what this does is this transitions
over to the serpent himself sort of
talking about what's going on now it's
not a great big huge long explanation
but one thing that we're gonna kind of
do here is we're gonna cheat a little
bit we're gonna sort of cover this and
then the next part and then we're gonna
we're just gonna skip over the uncanny
x-men and then come back to it in the
next video that we make so we're gonna
cheat a little bit uh you know we're
busily gonna kind of you know skip over
the part of unstoppable juggernaut I
kind of think don't think we should but
we're going to and in the next video
we'll cover that bit but in any event
with everything unfolding the way it is
the serpent really just kind of gives us
a synopsis of what he's done so far
which is say what it is that he's
shooting for and all he's doing is
powering himself by fear and that's the
whole basis that's one of the things
about normal humans in Marvel Comics and
Marvel Comics when it comes to average
everyday people it's usually that
they're like the most annoying part of
the story because by and large they just
get really scared and run away but
that's really the big the big thing that
happens every once in a while like a
person might step up but by and large it
is kind of running hide and let the
superheroes do all the heavy lifting and
so in response to this with humans being
so so really so timid in relation to
like the greater universe out there when
a being of significant power shows up
they react with fear and that feeds the
serpent at the same time Odin is
basically not really rebuilding asgaard
but essentially having the the wheels of
war perennial prepared having the
Asgardians get to work on building more
weapons different things like that now
in reality and one of the things that
people would ask is why aren't the
dwarves doing
and in truth is probably just to kind of
push the story the dwarves were really
some of the crew at some of the greatest
you know weapons masters and the
entirety of the Marvel Universe
I mean that includes like every
everybody the dwarves make some of the
best weapons and so we Roden is going
through and creating weapons similar to
that this is an Asgardian war so it
makes sense that as Guardians would be
the one to build these things so that's
really what's kind of going on now at
this point we transition to the
aftermath of the death of Bucky and it's
kind of a cool thing because we end up
meeting up really with classic Nick Fury
now of course classic Nick Fury is
always alive because these classic Nick
Fury why wouldn't he be but well the
question sort of asked what is this
that's happening here and and what's
this serpent being that you know Bucky
had basically talked about Thor arrives
in chimes in and simply says the serpent
is a being that really only Odin knows
about and is known about for quite some
time now something I want you to notice
here is that Thor just kind of takes it
with a grain of salt he just sort of
throws it out there because by this
point it's to be expected
especially when you're Thor and you're
dealing with things like this it's par
for the course
Odin doesn't tell the Asgardians
everything and it kind of makes sense
because he has guardians are like
children for Odin you know you don't
tell your child everything because your
child doesn't need to know everything
and so it's much the same way when it
comes to Thor and Odin and the rest the
Asgardian Odin houses a lot of secrets
and those secrets are really just his to
keep and to let them out if time permits
or if he wants to
and so with a situation like this Thor
knows enough to know the serpent is a
very very old enemy of Asgard but that's
really about it but the bigger thing he
hits on here is that the serpent is
fighting with a full might of what's
basically Asgardian power behind it the
longer he stays here the more people are
terrified the more powerful he will
become until eventually he returns to
100% full strength and when that happens
it's gonna be difficult for anybody to
win and so what we end up doing is
basically picking up with Steve Rogers
he's kind of been kept in the background
the whole time and he's brought back out
basically read on to Captain America
uniform and it's business as usual now
with him is it's kind of chiming in and
saying look okay where do we stand with
everything and he's given the whole
rundown of everything that's happened so
far but Steve Rogers response is okay
well we have to act we have to do
something if we do nothing the serpent
will continue to get stronger
the Serpent's power developing and
expanding is not a result of the action
of the Avengers or the superhero
community it's a result of fear so if
they do nothing they'll basically be
sitting on the sidelines while the
serpent gets more and more powerful
because of this Oh with a serpent
drawing is energy and feeding on it more
and more
ultimately he finally reaches his quote
unquote final form if we had to give her
that that depiction and it's basically a
very young guy and so it's kind of cool
here because this dude is wielding an
insane amount of power I mean it's it's
crazy how much power he has to give you
perspective when Captain America
alongside the Mighty Avengers and the
the you know what's left to the regular
Avengers when they all show up here
they're basically doing their best to
fend off as best they can but they don't
really stand much of a chance now for a
second I want to sidetrack and I want to
pick up with with Iron Man now Iron Man
being here is actually kind of funny
because he shows up to like the old
ruins of Asgard what used to be Asgard
and Broxton Broxton Oklahoma and summons
own now that's one of the important
things to bear in mind here and Marvel
Comics is entirely possible for anybody
on earth to contact Odin whether Odin
will respond or not is totally up to him
that's one of the things to bear in mind
the idea of the of earth you know of
earth kind of being divvied up among
these various deities more or less these
godly beings is somewhat of a misnomer
all the various godly beings that exist
in real world religion exist inside the
Marvel Universe and you could talk to
any of them I mean you can you can try
to contact any other you can contact
Zeus shooting the contact Odin if they
want to listen to you if they're willing
to give you you know any measure of
attention if they'll give me an audience
will listen to you if nothing they won't
and so in this instance Iron Man shows
up and just screams out the name of Odin
and basically what happens is he gets
drunk and then starts yelling at Odin
that's basically what happens here you
know it's kind of interesting because in
order to get the attention of Odin it's
not really a soccer is only you have to
go to an altar sacrifice a goat and then
you know dance around nine times say a
prayer and then Odin will respond it's
one of these things works like if you're
worth listening to
then Odin will listen to you and we're
where our man starts talking to us
starts talking to Odin it's kind of
interesting because his response is I
didn't actually expect you to answer but
the funny response that Odin gives Iron
Man is basically saying but like you're
a friend of Thor like like you are one
of Thor's teammates as part of the
Avengers it's the only reason why I'm
talking to you right now and so it's
interesting because with Tony Stark
basically being drunk and just yelling
at Odin ah one does like what he starts
to talk about is the idea of how Odin is
leaving the entirety of Earth's
superheroes to fend for themselves and
Odin interprets this is Iron Man saying
I want you to give us your armies like I
want you to give us as guardians to
fight on our behalf or to fight
alongside us so we could protect the
Earth but Odin's interpretation is
entirely wrong and I oh man picks up on
this when
just kind of look this is I mean sure
this is our fight but like we're
mustering our forces here we'll fight
the serpent once basically all you guys
are dead there's nothing left and then
we're gonna obliterate the entirety of
the planet earth but I imagine sponsors
no that's not what I want I don't want
you to fight on our behalf I don't want
you to you know fight in our stead we
don't want your Asgardians to pick up
the slack for anything like that what I
do for a living is I make weapons like I
am exceedingly good at making weapons I
don't want access to your soldiers I
want access to your workshop I want to
blend Asgardian you know technology with
stark tech that's what I want to do I
want to create a whole new slew of
weapons designed to use your power with
my power and destroy the Serpent and it
was actually pretty cool and his end is
really awesome because it's basically
Iron Man developing you know Asgardian
slash stark technology using you know
his own ingenuity and so on so it's
highly possible I mean it's one of those
things were it's not like this is
unfamiliar territory to Iron Man it is
to a degree but he's been a friend of
Thor for so long that he's well-versed
and essentially just like navigating the
waters of using Asgardian energy or the
very use the very least understanding
how it works but he's made anti you know
he's made like for buster suits in the
past so it's not entirely you know
something that he's entirely unaware of
but at this point we end up having Thor
who had basically faced off against the
serpent and he was able and we wasn't
really able to hold his own but he was
enough of a challenge that the serpent
saw him as somebody that could
potentially get in the way and so what
he is of doing is having Thor face off
against Ben Grimm and me and the
incredible Fork now Thor fighting
against Ben Grimm is pretty quick and to
the point he's defeated pretty fast and
it's kind of interesting Thor literally
throws his hammer and summons it back so
does it back to himself and it punches a
hole through Ben Grimm much like you
guys probably saw in the story of
infinity when Thor destroyed a builder
but then he turns his attention to the
Incredible Hulk and this fight is hard
court I mean it is an absolute brutal
brutal intense fight I mean it's it's
it's balls to the wall and it's cool to
see because with these two guys you know
tearing through each other it's
literally blow for blow punch for punch
hit for hit but one of the things that
Thor says and this is a very very big
thing one of the things that storage
says is I can't beat you like I know for
a fact I've never been able to beat you
and the incredible ultra spawn says I
always knew that like I always do that
was a case and that makes sense I mean
The Incredible Hulk strength is
limitless Thor's strength is not so just
by logic and reason we know the Thor
would not have been able to defeat be
Incredible Hulk
in my mind I think it really comes down
to this Superman versus Incredible Hulk
style fight right like yeah that's one
of the big debates can superman beat The
Incredible Hulk
yes unless the fight goes on long enough
and in the Incredible Hulk will just be
too strong for Superman and then
Superman will be defeated but like at
the outset maybe he can maybe he can't I
don't know is probably a wash I don't
really care enough to argue the point
but with Thor it's much the same way you
know if Thorin nipped it in the bud
right off the bat maybe he can win maybe
he can't I don't know it's a crapshoot I
mean there's been fights where Thor's
won there's been fights for the
incredible hulks won it really just
comes down to which cure do you like the
most but at the end of the day with this
battle between the two again this is
also taking place at the same time that
everything's going on with like the
Serpent and withwith Captain America and
so on this is kind of a big moment here
in the fear itself and the reason why is
because when the serpent finally arrives
when he basically you know picks up on
the scene you have like the Avengers you
have Spider Man Spider Woman all that
kind of stuff Luke Cage and so on who
try to combat him and they all get dealt
with quick fast and in a hurry I mean
they're they're they're taken out right
off the bat they're not killed they're
all just basically knocked out right off
the bat and in turn Captain America
throws his shield to the serpent and the
servant breaks it in half now this is a
very very big thing because the only
time we've ever really seen this happen
is one if is a person with
reality-warping powers or to Thanos with
the Infinity Gauntlet we've never seen a
person by sheer strength alone shatter
the shield of Captain America that's
never happened before and that's a
pretty big deal the problem with this is
that in reality the event of Captain
America shield being shattered the way
it was during Infinity Gauntlet really
kind of overshadows this because the
event was so significant but essentially
what's going on here is the serpent has
single-handedly dismantled the entirety
of the superhero community and this is
kind of itching in stone that when the
incredible hoax knocked out into space
by by whole I'm sorry by Thor when he
sent flying you know into the atmosphere
and falls back down again that it's
really a stopgap measure
that's all this has ever really been a
stopgap these guys are nothing more than
just you know bubblegum on a leaking
wall
sure it stops it temporarily but it's
only a matter of time before the
pressure builds up and that that
bubblegum gets blown out of the way and
that small leak turns into a full-blown
flood so cuts exactly what's happening
here they're just kind of in the way at
the moment they're really more of a
nuisance than anything else and that's
basically what happens Captain America
chiming in to Hawkeye basically saying
like we have to stop we have to stand
down and when the question is asked why
Captain America says because we're gonna
lose like look at around you look around
you at everything you've seen like
Thor's defeated The Avengers are getting
wrecked two pieces you know the
Incredible Hulk is a bad guy juggernaut
the bad guy the serpent shattered my
shield with his own bare hands like
we're facing off against the force we
could not possibly hope to defeat on our
own and so it's not very often you see
Captain America do that in fact I've
only ever seen Captain America turned
tail and run twice this is the this is
this is one of those times the second
time was age of Ultron when Ultron razed
the entirety of Earth and Captain
America had just kind of given up he was
like there's nothing we can do until he
realized until he thought of dr. Doom's
time platform and so and you know with
those things in mind
fear itself is an amazing story because
it's basically like pushing the
superheroes to the brink it's presumably
the end of all things but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comics explain make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the rod
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]